[Music]
three two one action
hey you guys welcome back to
off-the-record ooh we talked about why I
got this in the biggest Adidas store in
the United States in New York is it new
fairly it looks used oh this you know
why I came for my good stuff wash it
with all my colors and so the whites
aren't as white as they should it looks
pretty white it's told me I have one
like that it's not likes fresh fresh
white it's you know it's been washed
white the nylon looks just like wrinkly
like an orange peel 90s kind yeah yeah
first door thing I genuinely did not
even a disc no no that I take that as a
compliment cuz that's in part of you
guys went thrifting yeah it's not so bad
that's what I thought
my cousin love that [ __ ] I like it too
it's just I wish it didn't smell like
you should go to Beverly Hills dude it's
all [ __ ] beautiful like shopping
enough to do that you really have to
love shopping you have to like go
through things and try things on and
then be like I Korat this or I could fix
this and but it has a smell like it has
a library smell yeah you know like an
old library books maybe the bay yeah
yeah you know when you [ __ ] open up
an old encyclopedia in the page it
looked like they've been stained with
coffee and they're yellow and brittle
and CDs yeah the kids will never know
know it right I can smell it right now
in a thrift store to me smells the same
but sometimes you get some clothes there
that are like oh this is an old man's
jacket smells like - you ever guys go
diving in the lost and found no where do
we where can you find the lost and found
go to elementary school an elementary
school did you know like if you don't
come home with the jacket that you went
to school to get jazz beat ya know so
I'll be like I got my ass beat and it's
on the next day I'm like [ __ ] off the
jack is still there and then in a trash
can
yeah a new toy yeah yeah the school that
I went to my god ain't that fold it out
and then so I thought it was funny like
if I would go in and search for it
it just felt funny or if I don't all the
way of my legs are just sticking and
then I thought like this thought wait
until all the teachers are like Bart do
you need help but no
okay and I was just dying to keep my ass
from eating meat you know what I thought
was pretty funny you guys witness on the
playground there was always like a shoe
a shoe one shoe it was always like one
shoe right and then I'm up it's always
different too and I'm always like please
write thoroughly well maybe my school is
just [ __ ] up because there would
always be just a shoe somewhere on the
playground in a name-brand and I'm just
like who the [ __ ] forgets a shoe no I
see that on the freeway don't like how
does that happen there's always a random
shoe somewhere we're in a wall or the
powerlines with the [ __ ] shoe strings
that makes sense yeah yeah they sell
drugs bro oh yeah yeah it's supposed to
be like that's like a signal is that way
that's where you would go to get the
drugs but you grew up in not the hood so
I get it I just thought it was a
delightful gesture yeah Stallman like
hooligans just trying to cause trouble
is the pair of kids yeah yeah my friend
did that though with his old pair of
shoes because he was like I don't want
these anymore and then they they're like
they tied it the the strings together
and then they just [ __ ] swung it and
it gets caught up there it's [ __ ]
done I've heard different about her
different reasons for why those are up
there too though like I think one time a
long time ago I heard that like that
means someone like got shot him at home
yourself they're not even real yeah
that's true when I was a kid we did
stupid ass [ __ ] like that
yeah just oh [ __ ] all the time man one
time me and the homies after youth group
we were just like being stupid and the
home he picked up a snail from a little
like from the grass and a white truck
was going by and he like flung it at the
truck and hit the truck and then um yeah
push the hill I know
and then um and then the truck stopped
and like reversed and was looking for us
and we also ran away in those and move
scurrying because we thought the man was
gonna like get it I hate your friend hey
that's a horrible
that's a horrible horrible sport I know
it's not going well guys sitting next to
you used to cut their [ __ ] eyeballs
oh yeah oh yeah their antennae see who
you're sitting next to before you uh
start I didn't do it on my own
my cousin taught me yeah though the
other person I mean little you do [ __ ]
like that god I feel like we still put
salt on the snails No I don't know he
taught me he taught me everything
I was like I was like four or five you
know why I learned that from an episode
of Tiny Toons because they were going
against some like snail and something
there was some joke I forget in the snow
got salt on it he's like no no my let me
see this is real and I put salt on the
snail and I'm like yeah it's crazy
they physically are so easily influenced
boys [ __ ] I remember we had like holes
in our playground and then that's where
the Gophers are oh cool
so during recess I would just stick my
arm in there try to grab I'm trying to
wait like like a pet one and the teacher
would be like bar what are you doing on
the ground I'm like I'm just waiting for
a gopher bites you're gonna get rabies
and about to get a shot in your stomach
and I'm like wow I pulled it out you
were trying to pet one let it go for ya
what a [ __ ] idiot
at that age were you like pointing at
him going you [ __ ] idiot yeah
guaranteed like seven or eight that's
adorable
yeah I think about 17 or 18 man I
remember everything a possum like in
real life
yeah yeah like really disgusting they
look like big rats yeah yeah even the
baby ones are gross and baby everything
is cute but not possums
oh hi baby possum there's a [ __ ] big
one that lives next to us and he
constantly scrambles up the tree next to
us tonight
I constantly think it's a man it makes a
lot of noise uh no he's just huge you
just used to be lumbers around if it's a
small man it could be a small man yeah
smaller like creepy looking man like a
shell Oh furry just like a ninja turtle
maybe have you seen that [ __ ] lately
we're like we're Al's have like long ass
legs and then I can't are you playing it
I'm like what this is real I'm talking
about how you put your ours is like his
big fluffy things if you lift this [ __ ]
up their legs go like up to a chicken
like Big Bird big bird dude and they
like [ __ ] they'll run up and [ __ ]
like have you seen owl running it looks
like a guy back
tugging his pants up
Ron do a run why would they run I begin
a lick of the tootsie roll pop wow look
at this [ __ ] it's so creepy I'm like
this cannot be real there was another
picture but now just sitting like
crisscross
if I could fly I would never want to run
right I'm like I thought what I'm like
if something happens to you while you're
running you doesn't maybe meet some
lifts like a little bit of weights it's
stupid and okay like it's wearing like
Mozart underwear yes like a little bit
of rocks beautiful two feet taller so I
don't trust it's like a lawn gnome I
want what I just want to go and then it
comes into you know those [ __ ] talons
though bud why don't you trust Al's they
don't blink they don't and they don't
stop looking at you in the eye
yeah thank you eye contact no better
than see I filmed this animal show I
don't know but they sleep they don't see
sleeping is different I never seen a
sleep an owl sleeping while there that
one looks like a tree look a camouflage
[ __ ] I find it hard to believe that
he's sleeping we have a bunch of owls
around our house really yeah
what the [ __ ] where are you I'm sleeping
Oh a bird person he's - man if they're
big enough [ __ ] yeah big [ __ ] barn
owl took one of our cat smells again
whoa
goddamn huge [ __ ] al - that's why I
have a personal vendetta against em I
get him I did this animal show and for
one episode we were feeding this blind
owl this little owl he's like kind of
like famous on Instagram - because if
you look into his eyes it looks like
like gala constellations yeah it's so
cool it's blind right yeah his eyes are
like black like the [ __ ] uncle
Charles
bone thugs-n-harmony video oh they're
just black with little stars if you play
music does it court this yeah did you
google them all yeah so how did you find
out I just googled with star eyes that's
literally hearing blind L with stars in
his eyes hey Zeus oh wow yeah it's so
pretty
you kind of look better blind like that
I know and then they can't take your
kitty - I like that
what if that was like the universe I'm
on stoner talk I didn't know already
stoner not so talk dude is just talking
man don't you ever see men in black yeah
we're all living in our right [ __ ]
stoner yeah I guarantee it here comes -
man in black by the way that guy in the
movie stupidest I know but that guy's
one of the that's one of the greatest
acting performances we're talking about
yeah yeah I believed he was possessed by
something like when I was a kid I was
like yes again hanging up exactly that
was makeup you rushed it
have you guys seen the new one yep no
Jerry anyway the new one it's what the
girl Oh what Thor with Hemsworth how was
it I didn't see it I mean it's men and
black I'll watch all of them I actually
really liked it really yeah I really did
I liked it a lot
I'll catch it on a plane oh you had a
touching moment I think so okay I
remember correctly
now I'm doubting myself I remember I
felt like that I liked it wherever you
weren't great that's what I remember
request me neither
they love they love every single Marvel
movie ever made well what's your least
favorite Marvel movie Doctor Strange you
didn't like Doctor Strange it was
[ __ ] wack why I didn't even know that
one existed
I like dreams and [ __ ] me too but why
didn't you want little inception yeah me
too but it doesn't is he just walking
through portals and going at different
places [ __ ] learning how to do the
portal stuff I don't know I liked it I
think Benedict Cumberbatch is [ __ ]
dope actor I just wasn't on time what's
your favorite Marvel movie memory HUD oh
but silver samurai because he goes a
little booty no he sucks hot as Logan
good Logan his life even the [ __ ]
star of Wolverine said that movie sucks
ass you know why I like it only because
of that guy's accent what do they do I
think spider-man 2 is still the best
Marvel movie ever made which would with
Tobey Maguire that one's very choice
that pulls my favorite they're so funny
the second one so good it's pretty good
alright man good Iron Man one is [ __ ]
missing the ant-man movies yeah those
are really funny I don't think I saw man
dude you would love I'll watch them in
movies they're funny but then you forget
it right after what's his name of the
Mexican guy oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah I love Michael Ben he's fun and
everything yes but he made movies and
there's a youtuber in one of the ma
movies this is a small scene
oh so that's all she did they didn't
continue to anything no no
did you guys ever finally see infinity
war I did no I I didn't see it was I not
supposed to choice very choice one time
when I was on JK it had been off like
six months and you hadn't seen it yet no
wow I haven't either I forgot it's like
a year and he's thought yes the last one
I saw was they were at the headquarters
and then they found us some [ __ ] and
then he's on the back yeah that's not
even every Marvel movie that is every
movie here at the headquarters and they
got the news and in there like all the
bad guys it's not infinity war by the
way was way better than endgame i
they're not the same movie no man catch
up we might talk about I watched it
before they went to war that one when
they just found out like comic book
people though I am cuz I grew up on that
set all for the girls which one did you
grow up on I was a big x-men dude okay
yeah like a lot of x-men commoner true I
like hot asian girls were hot and then
and then I was always a bad man guy yeah
oh you want the best villains by far for
me you gotta have the [ __ ] Joe
Pistone oh you got a family he's [ __ ]
the dopest with him Casey and I recently
started watching the 1960 the Adam West
the best one to much where was not funny
really it wasn't funny to me it was like
wait stupid did you see the shark
repellent yeah you don't get it I did it
because I'm like okay no cuz I got it up
to a certain extent like the first like
five ten minutes I was like oh haha
that's funny it's really bad but then
I'm like holy okay this is really bad
check your girls yeah
you buy the episode where Robin I don't
remember any of it girl it was like the
second episode yeah I remember watching
a little Riddler
that's why it's fun when he was first
with Riddler the car was dope really it
came to my school yeah came to my I saw
the car cuz Jeff Dunham was driving it
around dip down puppy guy yeah it's
funny in LA never seen this my mom you
guys don't remember watching it on TV as
reruns as kids
yeah it's nostalgic that's why it's good
yeah it's like cheesy SH it's also funny
I think that's true see the quality of
the camera quality is like whoa it's
like a living exactl you're watching for
the critics these shows for camera
quality I think Casey rubbed off on you
too much you're gonna hit all chose not
to wait why he did movies also moves
wait why did you I will say this why
didn't you love once upon time in
Hollywood thing because the camera work
was great I know I did like it for that
reason that's why I watched the whole
first season their face Steve I don't do
how do we get on this video wait you
like once of our time well this was
before I met Casey no know what's what
I'm in Hollywood
geo you just suffered a major defeat in
this war he was talking about today
anything was trash you thought hot ass
well I didn't like the story of
everybody my photography you didn't like
the movies you didn't like doing I don't
go anywhere
I agree he went nowhere I want you
that's not what she was saying oh she
was arguing the camera quality so don't
flip her mind on her I'm not I'm
agreeing with him he's agreeing with it
yeah yeah I like L'Enfant I'm out of it
you did okay just tell me what the ass
huh no no I don't know what ass we're
talking about
I liked feet though I don't know what
Tarantino always have two got feet in
the shade feet this one too um I liked
that it kind of like I like that it kind
of takes you on this like where is this
going and then it leads to over really
like
the blue [ __ ] Cena this whole thing
was out of the [ __ ] blue
and I really liked it you know other
Tarantino movies they that take you on
that same kind of journey where it's
like where is this going and then it
pays off but this one was like that
didn't even pay yeah for me does nothing
happen until the end and I feel there's
no steak I just wasn't interested I
wasn't mad because I feel like I don't I
don't know maybe I don't necessarily
need steaks every time what movie do you
get mad at that I didn't know I think I
didn't like the new Sherlock Holmes
movie with Will Ferrell I did not find
it I see that wasn't good oh I heard
those and normally when people are
[ __ ] on a movie from the previews
I'm like nah man y'all are trippin you
got to watch it like that stop worry
about the critics but this done I was on
the plane I like I can't I can't get
through it I had to turn it off and I've
never do that wow that's really I had to
do that watching the to check those
Buster's movie plane I was buzzed up
yeah woman yeah it was so boy I was so
boring and the jokes were so try already
weird you're just saying that as a man
yeah true yeah i'ma stand here and sit
next to someone like this you know it's
not ready for progress you know what I
hated was every time annie potts was
funny as [ __ ] in ghostbusters one yeah
like you don't mean like nobody who
likes ghostbusters one hates women like
Sigourney Weaver's [ __ ] dope in that
movie [ __ ] antipasto mazing that
movie like the idea that oh yeah a bunch
of sexes I mean I'm sure there's sexist
who don't like it cuz
yeah but bridesmaids killed it and if
they had that and ghostbusters
they tried too hard yeah this was funny
it was so funny and it wasn't like a
chick flick or whatever it's just a
funny movie I mean it just so happened
to have an off you note like leading
cast it's like what I think most people
do categorize that as a chick flick
though but you know what's romantic
comedy but yeah when they sold the movie
and in the trailers and [ __ ] do not like
a bunch of women being powerful that's
not how you sell a [ __ ] game you're
just like here's the story here's who's
in it is this funny or not and then
everyone [ __ ] loved bridesmaids but
with that shoe it's like hey why use
because chicks are in charge
good that'll be like
same thing is this it's like this hey
we're coming soon in a theater near you
this summer here's a movie where there's
an Asian guy full up it's a it's a bunch
of Asian people they're not doing karate
they're just chilling and you're rich
huh and the rich they're not that rich
they're just kind of rich but they're
gonna meet other rich Asians and they're
super rich crazy rich even and guess
what everybody's [ __ ] Asian and it's
like why do you why why do you keep
pushing that fact as if there's
something will see them there
what's the story but that's how they're
pushing the all-female thing is yeah
there's a woman and another woman and
even more women there's way man that's
the mistake of it the Mexican movies to
it like the Mexican American movies they
lead with like I understand what they're
trying to do but it just comes off so
like for their Mexican powered Mexican
struggles these are the Mexican
struggles are going through and it's
just like unrelatable or everyone else
it's a pandering right and then but that
that that's what's so funny about it is
that they sell the movie that way to a
they're trying to reach the world crowd
and [ __ ] but dude it's just sell them
the story you can cast over the [ __ ]
yeah make it make it an all Mexican cast
or whatever you want to do but the story
is what I want to watch movies for in a
world where a dad rejects his son and
then you go in there oh it's an
all-asian casts or all my Sikh class or
whatever and it's like that was a good
story I liked it it was it was very
human I felt connected but then you see
all the ages and there you pissed you're
like the [ __ ] trailer everything
every single thing for that movie was
like girls are in power you know it's
just like whoa bro it's just if that's
not the cell birds-of-prey bomb - right
yeah bombed and do they do all the same
trailer in no world words all about
women I mean kind of they're kind of
going hard on the girl power no power
and it just didn't really it's just a
million look you know what hat girl
power
[ __ ] Powerpuff Girls in it was a show
killed it for a long time
and it just it just
girls who were rocking it didn't have
didn't have to say it and make it corny
Sailor Moon
they just said it with her name how were
pucker
[Music]